these were the two equations we looked
at in the previous part of the lesson we
want to solve for the values of x and y
using determinants and matrices so we
wrote this system of equations in the
matrix form like this we have three
matrices here we call them matrix a
matrix X and matrix B a times X is equal
to B so if we multiply both sides with a
inverse we get X on the left hand side
and a inverse times B on the right hand
side so what we need is X as that will
give us the values of x and y we have B
and we can find a inverse using the
adjoint formula let's zoom out and find
the value of a inverse it will equal 1
over the determinant of a time's the
adjoint of a and there was a condition
which said that the determinant of a
should not be equal to 0 so let's find
the determinant of a first it will equal
2 times 2 minus negative 1 multiplied by
3 that will equal 4 plus 3 which equals
7 as it's nonzero the inverse of the
matrix will exist now let's find the
adjoint of a do you remember the
shortcut to find the adjoint of a 2x2
matrix interchange these two and change
the sign of these two elements as these
two are the same interchanging them will
also give us 2 and 2 changing the sign
of minus 1 we get 1 and changing the
sign of this we get minus 3 this is the
adjoint of a with these two we get the
inverse of a let's write it on the
right-hand side this is a inverse 1 over
the determinant times the adjoint of a
don't solve for the a inverse
immediately keep it as is you'll soon
know why now that we have a inverse we
come back to this formula X is equal to
a inverse times B matrix X is XY a
inverse is this and matrix B is 4 13
this is a inverse and this is matrix B
this will equal one over seven
multiplied by this product how do we
find this product of matrices the order
of this matrix is two by two and that of
this matrix is 2 by one as the second
and the third number are equal they are
compatible for multiplication and the
order of the resulting matrix will be
first number by the fourth number so the
order of the resulting matrix will be
two by one two rows and one column the
element in this position will equal two
times four plus one times 13 that will
equal eight plus 30 or 21 what about the
element in this position it will be
negative 3 times 4 plus 2 times 13
negative 12 plus 26 will equal 14 now we
solve this by multiplying the scalar
with each element if we would have
multiplied the scalar in this step then
this multiplication would have been very
difficult because each element would
have had the denominator 7 so we just
wait for the final product and then
multiply the scalar what will this
product be equal to 1 over 7 times 21
will equal 3 and 1 over 7 times 14 will
equal 2 that's it we have got the matrix
X the variable X will be equal to 3 and
the variable Y will be equal to 2 that's
how we solve a system of linear
equations using matrices we write it in
the matrix form then rewrite X like this
then we find the a inverse multiplied
with matrix B to get the variable values
in the next lesson we will try to solve
a system of three linear equations using
matrices